we're in the homestretch people yeah
that's right only 12 more days left in
this shopping season to pick the leader
of the free world if the polls are right
Hillary's well on her way to winning
this thing though my guess is that the
polls are gonna tighten significantly as
we get closer to Election Day as they
almost always do also polls are just
polls at the end of the day and nobody
knows what will happen until Election
Day itself I've been saying this for a
while now but I'm guessing that many
people aren't publicly saying that
they're supporting Trump out of fear or
shame or public humiliation so the polls
might not be as accurate as pretty much
everyone is saying they are whether the
polls are right or wrong anything can
happen in the next 12 days and knowing
this election anything that can happen
will happen just wait for the Trump once
groped a donkey Hillary's being funded
by mr. burns headlines the day before
the election a few really interesting
storylines have taken root over the past
couple weeks on the Clinton front it's
pretty clear that there was some sort of
coordination with axe who conspired to
create violence at Trump rallies
regardless of who you're supporting in
this election I'd recommend taking a
look at the project Veritas videos here
on YouTube while you should view them
with a skeptical eye because Andrew
O'Keefe of Veritas obviously is no
Hillary fan the videos do appear to
provide proof of her campaign doing some
seriously shady stuff to paint Trump
supporters in a negative light and
expose as much of this manufactured
violence as possible to our lapdog media
when you consider the project Veritas
videos and add in the continuing
information WikiLeaks is dropping about
the Hillary campaign colluding with
friendly sources in the media as well as
the DNC's rigging of the primaries
against Bernie it's pretty clear that
even the most ardent Hillary supporter
must acknowledge that there has been
major ethical if not legal violations by
her campaign on the Trump front there
are a whole slew of other issues first
the continuing allegations of sexual
assault surrounding Trump though none of
them have been proven true yet while his
words to Billy Bush about grabbing women
were crass words do not equal action and
until any of these allegations are
proven to be
true they remain just allegations
regardless of whether they are true or
not apparently we live in a quasi post
truth society where people get to decide
what's true depending on whether or not
they like the person this is a huge
problem because any of us could be
accused of anything I wish my friends on
the Left were a little more
understanding of this even when it's
politically expedient for them right now
to use innuendo to destroy Trump the
bigger concern here about Trump right
now is his rhetoric around the elections
being fixed you all know I'm no fan of
the mainstream media and I've
consistently called out the bad actions
of the Hillary campaign as I did just a
second ago
however Trump's saying that our
elections are rigged before they even
happened and with no evidence is an
actual assault on our democratic system
for all of America's faults we've always
without exception had an easy transfer
of power from one administration to
another this transfer of power from
Party to party has been a key to our
success as a nation for over 200 years
we accept the results of an election and
we put down the fight until the next one
while our elections themselves have had
issues just ask Al Gore in 2000 there
has been a respect for the process by
everyone who has run for the office
Trump is preemptively shredding this
contract we've always abided by
potentially laying the groundwork for
civil unrest and violence and guess what
when the Trump supporters are out there
on the streets protesting rightly or
wrongly watch how quickly the left will
be into the same state power they
usually decry in putting down those
protests true democracy must survive any
candidate whether you think that the
candidate is a crook or a narcissist by
the way I'm not making a false
equivalence here I think there are
wildly different reasons we should be
suspect of both Clinton and Trump
unfortunately these are the two were
left with and hopefully whichever of
them wins will prove me wrong either by
making us stronger together or by making
America great again my guest this week
is Hilary Rosen Hillary's a democratic
strategist often seen on CNN as well as
a partner at skb Knickerbocker a
strategy and media relations firm
Hillary knows the media landscape and
the Democratic machine well and we're
going to cover all of the issues I've
mentioned here and many more I know that
by just saying demo
kradic some of you will automatically
dislike her and some of you will
automatically like her for those of you
in between which is undoubtedly the
fastest-growing group in American
politics it's important to hear from all
sides and decide what you believe in as
I mentioned last week I see a new
political alignment happening right
before our eyes many classical liberals
conservatives and libertarians
are suddenly realizing we are at all
each other's enemies so regardless of
whether it's President Trump or
President Clinton we should be finding
allies in our fight to make America
same again joining me this week is a CNN
contributor the managing director of skd
Knickerbocker media relations firm and
an optimist according to her Twitter bio
Hilary Rhodes and welcome to the Rubin
report I'm good so you're an optimist I
know if it's said on Twitter then it has
to be true it's tough being an optimist
these days isn't it
you know I've lived in Washington so
much longer than I can really even admit
but it's like over 35 years and this
town will suck the life out of you like
literally like bodily suck it out of you
and so you know I've lived through the
Reagan years here I lived through the
Bush years then the you know the second
Bush years I and yet there's something
about it that keeps me believing that
the next person is gonna make it better
and you know honestly living through
Barack Obama has had its moments so I'm
gonna optimist you're an optimist is
this a prescription drug related thing
possibly it a drug free there are free
drug free all right very good
well most drug free yeah fair enough and
whatever it is I'm okay with don't test
me no test all right so you are a
Hillary supporter your name is Hillary
you've got one else she's got two you
are very Clinton supporter I my audience
is all over the place which I'm very
proud of so I know you're gonna get a
certain amount of hate so I'm just
giving you that's a trigger warning for
you or a bring it on or something like
that so before we get into Hillary
though cuz that'll be the easy part for
you why do you not
Donald J Trump you know it's funny
because I had this moment today so have
you paid attention to the you know the
Facebook live thing that they're doing I
saw I saw a little bit of mr. thermistor
tech right so I I literally went to post
that I thought that the Trump campaigns
Facebook live Daily Show is a brilliant
idea and I kind of went back and forth
oh should I not compliment him is that a
bad thing to do like well that will
people think then that I think that
Hillary should do a Facebook like oh my
god you're so [ __ ] overthinking this
but so the the you know I like Kelly and
Conway as a person I'm sure I'm gonna
get hate mail from our democratic
friends on that so I thought it was a
good idea as a person I find him an
unbearable narcissist I always have
found him to be boorish you know it's
not a coincidence that the only
congressional district in New York State
that Donald Trump lost in the primary is
the one that he lives in not a
coincidence like the people who know him
best like him the least so I'd like to
that is a fact you're not making it up I
will grant you that fact it's a fact
right he lost that congressional
district the way he lost his
neighborhood you know they did his
neighbors didn't vote for him
so you know I could come up with one or
two nice things about him I do think
that how much his kids love him it's a
good thing you know so I agree with
Hillary on that I do think that anyone
who can make a business out of just
using his name which is really what his
business has been the last several years
just using his name has to have some
sample as my grandmother would say but I
don't think it's particularly helpful
for anyone else because you know the
average still work in at work or laid
off in Ohio is not gonna be able to
create a business out of his name
so I I'm puzzled by by the affection for
Trump's business business skills but I
just find him to be kind of a terrible
person
yeah so let's back up and start with
what you first said which is interesting
about the Facebook live post and you
were good up because I suspect what you
were saying is that you were gonna post
something not necessarily praising Trump
but saying that this idea is right right
we're not we're not allowed to do that
anymore in this sort of hyper partisan
world so you know I did it anyway
because I'm I don't really live by
hyper-partisan rules but I did go
through this kind of process over
whether it's okay or not to just to have
that kind of civil analytical
conversation so as someone on the left
as a as a liberal or progressed in
yourself a progressive or a liberal
doesn't even matter to you yes what one
of those both myself I'm a capitalist
tool with a progressive activist heart
that's nice so so as that does that
dishearten you that you know when you
post something on your own Facebook page
that obviously are these are your fans
or your friends these are people who
know Hillary Rose and they know your
politics that even by posting I you know
Trump this TV idea is kind of
interesting orgies using Facebook and
inappropriate but even that's gonna
bring hate from the left which is
supposed to be the Tyler inside that
must drive you crazy there's so many
things about this election that drive me
crazy we you know civility has become a
partisan issue on kind of both sides
right to say something like all of a
sudden if you say I like Kelly in Conway
she's a good person all of a sudden is
like what are you talking about she's an
evil person or if you say actually you
shouldn't want to ban all Muslims that's
you know not a good thing to say you're
so partisan you're so against Trump so
like these kind of basic niceties that
you were kind of brought up to
Hajin would be the right way to live
every day all of a sudden it's caught up
in this sort of partisan whirlwind it's
a little frustrating I'm very proud that
I'm called a Lib [ __ ]
and a member of the alt-right every day
like I think that says something you
know like that's the best they could
come up with Li sorry now I get Lib [ __ ]
I'm a [ __ ] Servat if I'm a member of the
all right I'm a white nationalist you
know it's a lot yeah you are those
things I'm ashamed I should have told
you before you agreed to do this show
all right so let's let's talk about
Hillary though because I've found that
for me at least in the online space that
I live in it's been easier for me to
find people if the online space that
you're in right now I know you do the
mainstream thing but you're you're in
the online world right now teeny-tiny
dial-up thing rocks in the Hollywood
Hills not in the Hills I hear you but
I'm able to find more passionate Trump
supporters that I've had better
exchanges with then then Hillary people
the Hillary people have either been like
connected to the campaign somehow or
they or that I sense that a lot of
Hillary people are voting for her but
grudgingly so someone that as someone
that's not voting for her but grudgingly
can you sell me on Hillary Clinton yeah
I hear a lot I hear people say that
Hillary voters are unenthusiastic but I
meet a lot of enthusiastic Hillary
voters so I'm not sure where the
disconnect is coming from I think you
can look at people and sort of
categorize them by by ages and I just
had a couple of women in my office
earlier today one of them was a
millennial and they you know so they
don't she didn't know the Clintons of
the you know 70's and 80's the sort of
you know progressive middle-class
Clintons right you know before they
became a member of the elite class like
the rest of us have
you know so but what she really keyed it
on she's like oh my god
Hillary Clinton talking about sexual
harassment and making this be an
important issue in this campaign has
totally excited my friends and I because
this has been a real issue for us it was
an issue for us a few years ago in
college it's still an issue for us and
nobody else has ever talked about it in
public life like that's a really big
thing and so she's enthusiastic and for
a whole other set of reasons for that
you know pillar is giving voice to for
young women and yet for someone like me
who you know has worked and know worked
with her known her for a long time I
remember when she you know made sure
that after that disheartening defeat on
health care she came back and didn't
give up and pass the Children's Health
Insurance law that has you know helped a
lot of kids to this day so like I know
that kind of pragmatic thoughtful
engaging really wonky side of her that
is rooted in policy I love that side of
her I also happen to know kind of the
girls girls side of her that the one who
at lunch remembers you know who you're
dating and your family and the last time
she talked to you and you know I just
saw her recently actually at an event
and the first thing she said to me was
oh my you know I've been thinking about
you because you know our friend's
husband has cancer and are you you know
I wish I could do more you you know
taking care of her um you know that's
Hillary that's that's who she is
so do you think it's partly that because
of the over-the-top caricature that
Trump basically is that people are just
sort of whether you hate it or you love
it there's a certain attraction to that
it's clickable it's it's easy to
understand what it is where the word you
use pragmatics with Hillary it just sort
of seems boring or whatever maybe maybe
perfectly great and maybe what you want
out of a leader but that it maybe just
isn't for
for the 2016 Twitter age well I think
the answer the short answer is yes but I
think one thing we have to be proud of
with Hillary in this campaign is I think
she has gone at Trump with a little more
intensity and maybe a little more relish
than people thought she would personally
that was a conscious decision on her
part because she felt has felt like when
other people have gone after him earlier
in the campaign season they didn't get
as much attention for it and basically
she had the bully pulpit and she needed
to use it having said that the thing
that she has stayed pretty consistent on
I think is that she started out this
campaign with a lot of wonky policy
papers with a lot of positions with deep
you know not two or three point plans
but ten point plans on virtually every
subject and I stayed there has stayed
there doing roundtable events on all
sorts of subjects has you know
consistently we just saw it in the last
debate when someone was talking about
Obamacare it didn't get much attention
but Hillary actually recited the top
five you know benefits of Obamacare and
why it mattered and what we would lose
if we actually repealed that whereas
Trump was just like I gotta get rid of
it it's a disaster it's a disaster
you know he he didn't even really know
the actual policies that it mattered in
the legislation so I I think she has
consistently been that person this is a
really long run-on answer but to wrap
that up it's just she started this
campaign with goals of what she wanted
to do as president
I think she's ending up this campaign
you know outlining those same goals yeah
so the Obamacare one is an interesting
play because I have no doubt that she
knows her stuff inside and out I've said
it on the show many times but in it as
an example with Obamacare
you know we just heard in the last
couple days that there are these
double-digit rate hikes and things like
that so it's it's weird because on one
hand she has to defend the parts of
Obamacare that are obviously are working
and then at the same time people see the
headline you know they look back and you
know they hear Obama saying if you like
your panda can keep it we know that
wasn't exactly true we they said certain
hikes weren't gonna be true then people
see the headline which I'm sure I
haven't seen Drudge today but I'm sure
it's the lead thing you know
double-digit increases so she's sort of
caught by being part of the system where
she has to defend something and attack
it at the same time where Trump doesn't
have to he's outside so he can kind of
say whatever he wants right well you say
she's caught but I'm not sure that's the
construct that she I think she is
articulating for people the benefit no
question and if you're one of those 20
million people who now have health
insurance you really don't want your
presidential candidate out there saying
we got to get rid of this thing
so I don't I don't think she feels
caught well what about the people that
are upset about the increases right well
that's I'm saying I think I think you
have to be honest and recognize that
there are multiple audiences here that
that feel differently about this law you
know I'm a small business owner our
health care costs have gone up a lot in
the last couple of years but before
Obamacare passed our health care costs
were skyrocketing so I if this law
didn't solve all the problems in health
care and because there was a very
strategic decision to keep our health
care system in the private sector to
keep it relatively competitive among
companies you know that that you're not
gonna you're not gonna be able to
dictate what all of the price increases
are what all the plans are and and how
the outcomes are all right let's move
off Hillary that Hillary and and Donald
because there's a lot of other things
that we can talk about about media and
the type of work that you actually do
now and I want to talk about a little
cable news stuff as someone in media
relations at the moment do you sense
like a real sort of earthquake happening
just related to how we connect with our
politicians how
we demand they connect with us how
social media has replaced cable news in
a lot of ways just that everything
really this really does feel like to me
four years from now the election is
gonna be extremely different than this
which will probably be good for a lot of
reasons but this really does seem to be
an election taking place in two worlds
the traditional mainstream route and the
online world and they're just like
clashing and that's what's creating such
craziness yeah and I actually think
there are really three elections right
now there are those two there's sort of
cable world TV you know drama of the day
repeated all day long all day long on
cable TV then there's kind of the online
conversation that real people are having
with each other or ranting about with
each other right and then there's
actually the campaign that's out there
in the States on the ground organizing
where there is real organizing
particularly on the Democratic side and
the coffee shops and in the town halls
and community centers and things like
that where there really is kind of
old-fashioned shoe leather vote
targeting going on and it's rare that
those three you know campaigns have come
together and in moments this this cycle
I think that the what's the so I I think
this notion of the citizen voice is
stronger than it's ever been and the
pushback on conventional wisdom I find
that reporters are most outraged and
freaked out of all the things that
happen in this campaign the thing that
reporters hate the most is this Donald
Trump like don't believe the media the
polls are rigged this is all crave the
media's bias like it's sort of the
attack on the media the undermining of
the media's the credible source of
information about the campaign that has
people the most crazy and in some
respects their reaction to it only
reinforces it because they spend a lot
of time then killing the message which
ends up appearing like they're killing
the messenger so a good example of that
though what I thought was like a
ridiculous overwrought reaction to
Donald Trump saying he wasn't gonna
accept the outcome of the election
mm-hmm
because I just thought this is stupid
you know of course it's gonna accept the
outcome of the election he's just he's
he's foaming at the mouth he's doing
what he does and but yet for three days
it was the headline what do you mean if
we say that it's over it's over
notice how can somebody say it's not
over when we say it's over you know it's
interesting it's interesting because
that line I actually thought was and I
led into the top of the show with this I
actually thought there was some
legitimacy legitimate scary stuff with
that because it's a dog whistle to his
people if he loses to say that it wasn't
us it wasn't us but the system it's one
thing to say the media's messed up but
it's another thing to say that the
actual voting is rigged so I actually
did think that it was it had some cachet
would not I'm not giving a legitimacy
I'm just saying it had some like worth
to push back on yeah I understand but I
think of all things I think they're
gonna conflate whether or not the system
is rigged against them versus whether
people really believe that voting
machines have been hacked all right
those are two separate things yeah and I
don't I don't think that people will get
to voting machines have been hacked I
call me skeptical on that point but you
know the system is rigged the media is
biased regular people don't get a fair
shake your voice isn't represented I
mean that's Bernie Sanders too right
that's not just Donald Trump well that's
the funny thing they both were the
outsiders but okay so as someone that
does this that is a Democrat in media
relations and cable news and the whole
thing is it fair to say that there are
more Democrats generally in media than
there are Republicans or conservatives
there are most of the people are liberal
that's that's fair to say right give me
a give me a meter relations answer come
on well I'm gonna split this up I think
what we have seen
additionally in the Republican Party at
their national candidates and ever since
kind of the right-wing took over
Republicans what you end up having is
sort of a real split on social issues
and I think that there's no question
that my experience in them in the media
world that there are more sort of
socially liberal people you know media
folks and there are socially
conservative media folks and so then
whenever candidates put emphasis there I
think that that has that has created
bias
I think the Trump issue though isn't
really about you know Democrats versus
conservatives I think it's just that
people are offended at how much fee lies
I think people in the media are just
appalled at does the kind of you know
bad fact machine robot like person that
he is and and tries to encourage other
people to be and and and I think people
are just incensed by it and in the media
and so they're constantly pushing back
on him particularly in the last you know
six or eight weeks when it got more
serious and so but I don't I I don't
think that they'd be treating MIT Romney
this way or I don't I don't think they'd
be treating Marco Rubio this way I think
this is unique to Donald Trump yeah but
really I mean with with Romney you know
there was the binders of women and the
47% Lee you don't think at this point
they breathe pretty much were saying
Romney was an t woman at this point so
isn't it just that's sort of what the
Republican is gonna get like I think a
lot of people are looking back and going
man maybe we should have been a little
nicer to MIT because look at this yeah
I'm not sure the binders of women was as
much a media thing as an effective echo
that the bomber campaign made happen but
I you know so most of my reporter
friends honestly don't vote
and is that a premolar laziness you know
that they find that important so I I
actually don't
but do I experience them as generally
socially more progressive and yes but
also you know I do think there's this
path of socially progressive fiscally
conservative if there were a candidate
down those down that middle path
you know you'd find a lot of media more
apt to be there yeah well I think that
that's where most of the country is I
think they're fiscally conservative if
they really understood economics and I
think they're for the most part but
obviously not the fringes are socially
liberal but I'm curious it's someone
that's been in this for a long time and
you're you're in the the DC crowd and
the media crowd and all that stuff in
the crowd you're enduring the crowd
you're very proud you're very popular
amongst the popular people that are in
DC tourism what do you think about the
the sort of level of friendliness in
general between the media and the
politicians I mean you know we could
look at any cable network and the amount
of people that are considered analysts
that either work on campaigns or have
worked on campaigns or who are actively
working on super PACs I don't even need
to name the people so I won't put you on
the spot but there's plenty of people
that then leave there to go work for the
DNC or work but like it's just this big
orgy and and people I think are really
legitimately sick of that so as someone
that has a little insight into that how
do we how should the average person view
that I think in you know and I I've been
at MSNBC and CNBC and CNN so those my
experience but I think that the network
in some respects looks at people like us
as cheap talent and then there's a lot
of free talent because there are a lot
of people who you know come on
with expertise for free and I thank God
you said that because every time I've
gone on HLN they never pay me and I
thought maybe it was just me but yeah
it's not an anti rubin thing I do think
you know that that producers and
Booker's try and look for people to come
on these shows that bring something to
the table and I don't think that it's a
disqualifier that one of the things that
they also bring to the table is having
been having been in the room and that
sometimes they're still in the room you
know the room where it happens and so I
think that that's something that viewers
have historically been interested in
from an app you know an analyst point of
view but I do think that it has the
potential to turn into kind of a feeling
of coziness that there is a there's a
room where things happen for people who
are invited into the room and if you're
not invited into the room you get
screwed and I think that that's why you
know like like I think it's CNN we have
anchors like you know frankly Anderson
Cooper Jake Tapper people who don't see
themselves as particularly political and
will ask people questions like regular
people talk and so I I think that's
really important I think that we can be
on TV interpreting what's happening in
the election for people who don't live
it day in and day out interpret does
that mean if the poll says this and one
stayed in a poll in another state how do
you reconcile that and how might a
campaign make a decision about where to
disperse resources so people like me can
bring that kind of expertise to the
table and then people like me can argue
on behalf of a candidate and trash
another one right so we're gonna bring
those two things but I'm not gonna
pretend to know details about the job
search of a laid-off factory worker in
Ohio I'm you know I'm I have empathy for
it I want to see good public policy
about it but I'm going to depend on CNN
to
Ohio and and find ways for those people
to talk for themselves and to find like
real representatives for it
yeah do you think part of that part of
the problem is just a human reaction
like once you're invited to those
parties I always think the White House
Correspondents Dinner I used to be
friends with someone in a public person
I don't have to mention him who would
rail against it he thought it was the
worst thing ever you see the media's in
bed with the administration and they
hate it and hated it and then last year
got invited to it now he's all about it
so right so that there's some element of
it's almost like the the powers that be
can kind of invite you in and everybody
wants to go to the cool part you know
they call it the nerd prom which sounds
so douchey and me but like they you know
they want they know ah you got into the
party once you're around these people
you enjoy the good food and the
cocktails like you're gonna ease up a
little bit it's just natural human
reaction do you think that's fair do you
think that's a fair estimation I know
not for everybody but I think for a
certain amount of the reporters that are
around it it's like you want to be in
the club look I'll just take Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton as an example
I don't think either one of these have
had reporters this year ease up on
either one I think part of it is timing
Hillary had a really rough year and a
half this last six or eight weeks people
have said all right we've had a really
we really dissected her and gone off on
the emails and gone off on the Benghazi
and done like everything and now we're
they're still going after her on
WikiLeaks and and other things but
Donald Trump had had a you know by a lot
of media accounts a good scape there for
a while and so now he's getting you know
his rectal exam and and I think in some
respects it's it's a timing issue that
people are paying attention now in a way
that they didn't pay attention before
but I do not think either one of these
candidates feel like the press has been
cozy with them and I think if you look
at
House and Senate candidates or local
candidates that are subjected to maybe
end up there's been less emphasis in the
media on some of those other races
because the presidential election is
such a you know car accident that you
can't you know take your eyes off of it
yeah but so I think maybe on some of
those races there's less focus and there
needs to be but I don't see this as kind
of a clear sale for either of these
folks all right so you briefly mentioned
WikiLeaks over there I didn't know as a
Democrat if you were gonna bring it up I
had it in my notes here but you did
bring it up so tell I mean are you guys
concerned do you think over our election
that's my line and I'm sticking yeah no
I mean really what all right as a media
relations well first up just tell me
what your general thoughts are on the
content do you believe the content to be
real that's a great question actually
because you know we do a lot of work
with the DNC here and we just had a
situation last week where there were
emails to the DNC supposedly from John
Podesta and they were fake and so it all
of a sudden we said we you know kind of
believe to what people have been saying
all along it's like wow there really can
be planted emails in this huge dump so
as a practical matter no I I don't feel
like I could say that they're they're
authentic okay so separating from that
which it seems to me the jury seems to
be out on that and you know I attended
Sirota on this week who is saying that
if the DNC or Hillary campaign could
have you know for sure said we even
found one fake one that certainly they
would have let us know but well I think
you could just chalk it up to we're not
totally sure at the moment the Michael
Isikoff story and Yahoo the other day
because
they gave him the fake emails to look at
okay investigative reporter all right
I'll definitely take a look at that
all right so removing that portion from
it okay as someone that again has worked
with campaigns and things like that do
you think there's anything in there you
know I know there's stuff that's not you
know it sounds like they're giving
stories to friendlies at the New York
Times or some you know some stuff that
kind of sounds like pay to play
I mean stepping away from the campaign a
little bit do you think there's anything
in there that that really strikes you as
untoward or or really bad I don't I feel
like it's the kind of day-to-day
back-and-forth that happens on any
campaign the should we do this or this
is the downside of doing that and so I I
haven't really seen anything where I
thought oh [ __ ] that's really really bad
what about what about giving stories to
friendlies as they've called that we
know that that obviously exists and that
goes to what I'm talking about before
about just the relationship between the
press and politicians but do you think
there's something that at least even
just even if it's just optics do you
think there's a problem there well not
for the campaign it you know it's not
it's not great for the media outlet but
I don't think it's bad for the campaign
because the campaign is doing its job I
think for the media outlet you know
again you have to look at the whole of
the of the coverage I don't think that
people would say that the New York Times
has been easy on Hillary Clinton now the
last couple of weeks they've been really
tough on Donald Trump but as I said I
don't you know I don't think you could
you could argue that they gave her a
free ride so I I don't think that those
were any sort of you know major problems
and you know there are a couple of other
things in there that I think were
embarrassing you know conversations that
they probably would really not want to
have public if they were accurate but I
didn't say anything
really troubled me that much I sort of
felt the same way around the excerpts of
the Goldman Sachs speeches which is
there didn't seem to be anything in
there that was so troubling what was
more what about the line yeah what about
the line about you know you guys are the
experts so you should kind of police
yourselves well she didn't say you
should police yourself she said you
should participate and that was a big
difference there and I mean that's just
factually true you are experts it
doesn't mean there aren't there aren't
other experts to who need a seat at the
table but I don't see anything wrong
with inviting industry to the table I
don't think they've been on the table or
run the table but I think that how can
you make smart laws if you don't you
know have people there who are gonna
tell you its impact you don't always
have to believe them but you want to
hear it yeah let's clip back to Trump
for a second because this reminds me
sort of if you were handling him if he
was coming to you for sage wisdom
he'd probably probably pay a lot for
that right that's not that would not
come cheap to try would not be eight
that would not be cheap I don't know if
there's enough money in Trump Tower to
pay me so but if he came to you and what
you said before about the line that we
know I mean we see every day the amount
of lies that he lays out per day
sometimes I think they're somewhat
overblown but we know it's just like a
factual mess the things that he's saying
every day it's like turnips or something
with him so as a media relations person
it seems pretty obvious to me that
despite the lies he just has forged
through them and that and that he said
you know what was the line about I could
shoot someone in the middle of the
street and nobody would care it's like
he's realized that the more he doubles
down on this the more that it works in
your history of media relations have you
ever seen an example of something like
this before never never can I say that
more emphatically never I've never seen
this and in fact you know if I had a
client that I was media training
you know it would be that kind of
cluelessness about the about the impact
you were having that I would try and
beat out of them you know I you know
make them practice and rehearse over and
over again to try and look like they
actually cared about someone other than
themselves you know and what does that
say what does that in our line of work
then if it's if it's even if he loses
the election that he has sustained this
for so long
treating the media this way what does
that say well we'll look at the numbers
right because you can get some people to
believe anything but it's what you get a
majority of people to believe so he's
got the biggest audience he's ever had
in his life and and you know in his
career maybe for his future 36 percent
is great you know what were the Trump
hotels market shared before then right
so i but i but it's not persuasive to to
a majority of people and it's not
effective it's it's working with some
people but i it's not working with most
people yeah
all right let's step away from all the
day to day election stuff and the media
stuff at the same time and just talk
about politics in a kind of broader
sense even though you're a Democrat
would you like to see more parties I
mean it's really hit me more than ever
I consider myself independent but we
desperately we desperately need more
parties I would love if there was an
actual you know libertarian or classical
liberal party I think if we had a
functional not Jill Stein lead Green
Party I think that would be fine do you
think even though even though you
obviously like the Democrats do you
think that for the health of democracy
that we need more parties wow that's a
big good question right I I know your
paycheck is slightly related to the
answers so you know what's not really
I think that that it would be freeing in
a way if people could narrow their
interests more you know I'm I'm a little
more of a centrist Democrat on some
things and a little more less than other
things so but and and I think that we're
going to see a really significant
struggle in the Republican Party over
the next six or eight months but to
reconcile their factions but I'm not
sweeping under the rug the factions in
the Democratic Party so it's a it's
appealing to think about it and imagine
that then we could have real coalition
government as opposed to partisan
government you know we we've seen it
work in Europe and then we've seen it
sort of blow apart in Europe so um I
guess I'm open to it but I think it's a
function of I guess it feels hard to get
to yeah
what would you tell Hillary if she wins
we somehow got right back to it but what
would you tell Hillary if she wins about
reaching across the aisle and look no
matter what she does assuming she wins a
certain percentage of the Trump people
an extremely high percentage you're
gonna hate her no matter what what would
you tell her as far as if you want to
get even ten percent of them that might
be malleable and flexible in thinking to
come on board well how would you
instruct her to do that I think she
actually understands this question very
well and you know as a you know
president you're not a dictator but in
in this instance if we have multiple
factions you are a little more like a
prime minister and a president in a way
because you have to find ways to bring
Republicans together Liberal Democrats
together with centrist Democrats you
have to get some moderate Republicans in
I think the Republican majority in the
house is gonna shrink some and the next
speaker will have to decide if they're
willing to pass things with some
Democratic votes because there's gonna
be a faction of right wing boats they're
never gonna get if they try and come to
the table so I do think that Hillary
actually is a really good leader for
those times because she's not so
politically bound you know people see
her as such a partisan but in fact she's
really not she's more she's more issue
focus than she is politically focused do
you think you'll miss the old school
Republicans I mean this split that's
breaking like did you ever think there
would be a day where you'd suddenly be
like you know Paul Ryan and Lindsey
Graham and a couple of those old guys if
Paul is not old but like just the
lighting funny that you know Paul Ryan
and Lindsey Graham used to be considered
fairly right-wing I think it's funny
that they're now the moderates you know
when I'm old so to me is sort of the
moderates were like Arlen Specter and
Lincoln baby and people like that so you
know they're they don't even exist in
the Republican Party anymore right so to
that point do you think they'll you'll
miss summer just whatever whatever the
old Republicans are be it from the arlen
specter's of the back in the day to paul
ryan now that like that thing that
republican conservative thing short of
them having some crazy resurgence
assuming Trump loses and they they go
back to their roots I mean it really
seems over do you think you'll be
nostalgic for it ever oh I already am
because I it's so you know people like
that who have first of all help social
progress like I'm a LGBT activist in my
spare time and if you look at the you
know the few times we actually won votes
on Capitol Hill we won votes with
Republicans we you know wasn't just yeah
we got the majority of Democrats but we
stopped the constitutional amendment to
ban you know same-sex marriage with
eight Republican votes in the Senate
and the majority Democrats that couldn't
happen today
we we couldn't find eight Republicans to
vote with us on an issue because they're
so you know there's such bad
consequences for them to cross over
party lines on issues and so I think
that that you know we're more poorly
served as a country without our
moderates yeah I'm curious that my
audience knows I the left more because I
consider myself part of the left as a
liberal are there anything is there
anything going on on the left right now
that you're not thrilled about like when
it comes to some of the political
correctness stuff or the free speech
stuff or any of that do you see cause
for concern or am i blowing it out of
proportion on Twitter no I think I think
there's a you know a couple of things I
where you see we see just sort of
demonizing anyone who works on Wall
Street like I I don't get paid by anyone
in Wall Street I have no clients on Wall
Street I have no dog in this fight but
that doesn't mean that I don't think
there isn't like some expertise around
financing that is still kind of useful
to have somewhere around the government
I'm I'm a clean air and clean water
advocate I'm happy that we are moving
towards wind and solar an alternative
energy but I don't I don't see how we
you know we're not there overnight right
we need some interim steps I you know
people are not giving up their cars they
don't we still want our houses cleaned
we need a backup generator as it were so
the sort of the purity caucus I think is
where I end up kind of parting ways and
I'm I'm much more conservative for
instance on taxes I if a company makes
money and wants to hire more people with
that money it's like fine I'd rather
them hire more people than pay a higher
corporate
taxes which is I know an enactment of my
liberal friends right I'm with you if
they if they take that money and pay it
out to their executives we oughta tax
their income really well let tax them
high you know like I don't I don't like
the disparity between CEO pay and
regular worker pay I think that's
obscene and so if they end up using
their corporate profits to pay their
senior executives a lot of money then
that those people should be taxed a lot
on that income but if they want to use
their profits to create jobs and more
growth and more opportunity like I'd
rather see the money go there yeah so so
when you see or what happened with
Trump's taxes and the 980 million
whatever knowing that what that assuming
what he did is legal because no one's
saying it's illegal but you don't have a
moral problem with it like that's more
of like a systemic I do that's that's
personal income tax right that you get a
ridiculous amount of benefits from real
estate in particular like the the
esoteric nature of taxing you know real
estate professionals is that's obscene -
it's your your assets appreciating but
yet you're depreciating the you know the
the buildings that you own it that makes
no sense to me right but but you're you
make the distinction between him just
using the law which he did versus doing
something illegal right you there's no
like what he did basically but but a lot
of people do it oh I don't like what he
did and I don't I don't actually think
that that's a good you know it's not a
good use of corporate dollars so I I'm
all for him paying significant taxes
there I I'm making a different
distinction like of a a company or a
small business as earning money and with
their profit they are growing their
business hiring more jobs I'm not
talking about taking a loss I'm just
saying my interest is not in raising
their taxes Roger
my interest would be in raising the
taxes if they pay their bosses too much
money yeah all right I - I have two more
questions for you and then and then
you're free to go to the fancy DC
parties or
I know I'm gonna get all these like
crazy notes on this dude attack you of
mine but whatever the Twitter people are
gonna be out the Trump people on Twitter
they just are if I bring that if I don't
write me about my tax views I'm like not
an expert you just asked me if I thought
about like where we get a little too
crazy on the web
trust me even by be asking certain
questions they yell at me it's okay
that's what free speech is all about
though
so two questions before before we end
here after this election do you think
there's gonna be just like a little
brief healing period cuz I actually do
like just where people just November
nights gonna come one of them is gonna
be the winner I actually do think
there's gonna be a couple weeks of like
we're in this thing it just feels so
intense for everybody even my friends my
best childhood friend who is not
political at all if you asked him who
the vice president is right now I don't
think he would know but he's been all
about this election do you think there's
just gonna be some natural cathartic
thing that happens in the country after
this I think there will be a big exhale
like oh my God thank God it is over yeah
I I do worry about Hillary Clinton I
think it's gonna be hard to be Hillary
Clinton you know to to get up and and
find the words that make the entire
country believe that you can move past
what has been such a you know ugly
unhealthy conversation is hard and well
maybe scratch that some of the
conversation actually is healthy right
some of the stuff that you know when
Donald Trump is gross about women like I
said people there's been a really great
conversation about sexual harassment
that we wouldn't have had otherwise but
but it's not that this election has not
brought out the best in America and I do
think that people want the best in
America so I'm hopeful that she's gonna
give it a give it a good show at the end
fair enough all right final question on
the record what are the percentages what
are what are we looking at here after
rely on Election Day Wow
I'm asking that's right that's right I
have been thinking that she would that
the winner would not break 50% because
of the third party candidates and and
the like but I actually think now that
that she could get 51% of the popular
vote and he'll be in the high 30s and
we're gonna see a stronger third party
vote than we anticipate it that's my
prediction all right listen I tried to
do my best to help Gary Johnson I did a
whole video about how we got to get the
guy to 15% and let's do it unfortunately
he didn't live up to your own faith in
him no he didn't I feel like he owes me
a steak dinner that's what I've been
tweeting Hillary it's really been a
pleasure you know you did my old Sirius
XM show you were like one of the first
like real people we got on when we were
a struggling little thing and I really
appreciate that and I appreciate you
joining me today I love your Sensibility
keep at it all right thanks so much and
you guys can follow Hillary on the
Twitter it's at Hillary our that's just
with one L don't get her confused with
the other Hillary although people have
gotten confused am i right now no one's
ever gotten confused oh yeah there was a
story actually yeah there was a story I
want to look like Hillary Clinton so I
could be a look-alike and after she's
president there couldn't work in that
all right Hillary thanks so much
you